michael's
bright idea to try to convince angela to
move to nigeria
backfires on him big time
why did you act like that shut up hey my
90 day fans fam
it's melisia here we have a lot to break
down when it comes to this fight between
angela and michael so i'll break down
the other highlights from the latest
episode of happily ever after in just
a few okay let's go ahead and do a deep
dive into
what went down between angela and
michael
everything was good between these two at
first
angela showed him the suit she bought
him for their wedding
and his reaction had me on the floor
oh my goodness oh my god these are
expensive
yeah pretty much this is gonna be war
after
the
[Music]
that was so cute it was so cute
the little boy came out of michael look
i wish
all men were that excited to wear suits
i really do unfortunately michael's joy
didn't last for too long
because something convinced him that it
was a good idea
to take angela to meet his male friend
dawa
and some other people who have made the
move from the us
to nigeria with hopes of convincing
angela to stay there i
cannot live here i mean i'll listen i
respect
your friend but i'm not moving here
i can't just up and move my family
depends on me my grandchildren depend on
me
my mom depends on me you know not only
that i i'm an american woman i can't
give up
hot water electricity i'm spoiled i
can't live like that
when they got to the place michael's
friend dawa was
nowhere to be found the only people that
were there
were daoa's female friends and we all
know
how angela feels about michael having
any communication with women
outside of his family when angela saw
those girls
she was so pissed that she had to do
this
she had to look away twice
[Music]
oh poor girls they looked terrified
this one in the middle was so nervous
that she couldn't let go of her shirt
angela decided that she was not going to
stay but
i did admire the fact that she showed
the girl some respect
before she left i thought it was a guy
we was talking to
matter of fact thank y'all for coming
i'm done thank you
i appreciate y'all for coming thank you
thank you very much
that's a wrap mike did she just freak
out
i'm done i want to be away from you
there's not going to be a marriage
[Music]
child woman tell me what going on in
america michael
was speechless the entire time i guess
he knew if he opened his mouth
it would be hell to pay and it was
why did you act like that shut up don't
wait right after their argument
a scary call from skyla about angela's
mom
struggling with dementia helped calm the
situation down
and it put things back into perspective
for the two
as of right now their wedding is back on
i spoke with angela about a month ago
and i asked her what's her response to
people
who say that her reactions towards
michael are just
over the top check out what she had to
say i don't mind their opinions i don't
get mad at their opinions i don't get
mad at what they say
because at the end of the day i have to
live this life with michael not them
and they're always looking inside the
house you know nobody tells at all you
know what i mean
there's got to be some kind of privacy
between you and your man or you and your
woman
but i just say i'm
inviting them to see our journey i'm not
inviting you to tell me how to live
my journey our next and final highlight
goes the colts mom miss debbie clashing
with jess he went from one brazilian
relationship and now he jumped into
another one i understand
and also she needed it she needed a
green card and
it could be that you might need a green
card
i don't have problem living brazil again
it's no problem for me
but now i have codes so
yeah yeah you do miss debbie said
yeah you do yep she gave jess that look
well next week on happily ever after
larissa moved in with eric
after being kicked out of her friend's
house and they're already having trouble
i found out that erik was passing to a
girl
behind my back hello hello natalie
do you know my boyfriend eric julie
talked horrible things about you
he also talked about like intimacy
between
all right my 90 day fans fam well make
sure you stick with e.t
because we are covering it all see you
next time
you